we often hear it's impossible to get a
screenplay read and especially now so
many new writers want to get in
to netflix want to get a meeting with
someone
is it impossible no it's not impossible
but i think you have to calibrate you
have to be
realistic i mean people talk about
netflix a lot certainly
it's the big line in the jungle and
we see a lot of good projects being
produced are required
so that's great uh netflix is actually
one of the companies being as big as
they are
it's understandable they're a company
who basically advertises they have a
policy that we
if we don't have an existing
relationship with you don't knock on our
door
so it would seem logical
that people would have this feeling like
oh i can't get red
but there's but it's but it's really not
what it seems
what they're really saying is invest a
little time
make yourself known to us how do you do
that
um when the case first of all there's
there's
there's a couple of dozen very vibrant
streamers
not just netflix they're not the world
of streaming they're one of
the biggest of and there's a lot of
places that you can go
who don't have you know the policy of we
don't accept unsolicited material or you
can't come pitch us whatever it might be
but if you really want to get in the
door it reminds me of you know back in
the day when
carlos antenna wanted to play at
fillmore west up in san francisco and
bill graham
the empresario was like i don't know who
this kid is
and he you know people you knock and you
knock and you knock it's like jeffrey
castenberg
always used to say if if you can't get
in the front door go through the back
door if you get in the back door
climb through a window if you can't go
in through the basement there's a way in
and that's true well carlos santana
climbed up a drainpipe on the exterior
of the building to the third floor and
fell through the window into bill
graham's office
that's how they met well i don't
recommend that necessarily
but it worked it started his career
by the same token if you want to get
into netflix
how hard is it to research who are all
the people who've either
produced for them an original or had a
film
acquired by them and cozy up to them
this is a team sport this is it takes a
village
to get any project made series feature
limited series docu-series whatever
so you're going to want to be knowing
these people regardless well why don't
you just find the ones who are doing the
kinds of projects
genre budget that are similar to yours
who happen to have that relationship
and go that route there's a lot of ways
in
but there's the other and and the other
way is
there are a lot of people who work at
netflix
befriend them
it's not all this is not a like a pass
fail report card
or menu of options it's a human reality
if you really are determined to get into
netflix there are people at all levels
from
from assistant all the way up uh where
you can identify
them and you can find them on linkedin
they're they're named
and you can reach out to them and you
can do what we were just talking about a
moment ago which is
introduce yourself but not to say i want
a pitch meeting or i want you to read my
script
i just want to get to know you because
what happens is if you actually invest
a couple of short calls doing that over
a period of weeks
that prohibition against we don't deal
with strangers or we don't read
unsolicited material
vanishes it evaporates because now
you're not unknown
that's a human metric and you can
overcome that
um i'll share a quick story about
many many years ago i always when i have
a project
i always put together what i call a top
100 list
who are the people that ideally in every
category
that i want to that i would want to
approach to talk about this project
from editors and writers and
cinematographers and casting directors
to producers to buyers
studios streamers you name it
and i will just go through that list and
prioritize them
and i'll reach out to them and usually
again it may not be the name on the door
or maybe it is
um but the idea um
the story that i want to share is that
years ago i i made a list
and um it wasn't arrogance it was just
i'm it was a dream so i added a name to
my list
that was the most preeminent name in
hollywood
at the time and probably still is steven
spielberg
so here i am a little guppy and i put
the name of steven spielberg on my list
and i think you know you know normally
you would think oh
sober up child it's not going to happen
but as it turns out i had gotten to know
this wonderful guy young guy
named mitch who was an entry-level guy i
met him when he was an assistant he got
promoted to creative executive and he
was now a creative executive at
amlin his ultimate boss was stephen
and so i spent some months just
nurturing that relationship and one day
someone sent me a script and it was
absolutely gorgeous
it was beautifully crafted a story young
characters kind of a very special care
very emotional
young young leads
but it was just tremendously well done
so i called up this fellow whose name
was mitch and i said mitch
i read this script we'd been
co-conspirators we're both starting out
in the business we were friends now
new friendship and we were excited
so he read it and he called me back he
read it on the weekend the usual monday
morning call back and he
he called me back and said he praised it
he said this is absolutely gorgeous it
was very emotional it took me back to
when i was that age i had a
not dissimilar experience fabulous thank
you it was really really interesting
it's going to be a pass and i said okay
mitch
um one favor
why why is this a pass you just
you were just singing at spratuses and
it's because it's too small for stephen
i said okay that's fair i understand
that
but let me ask you a question if you put
the script in steven's briefcase for his
weekend read and he were to come back
monday and say to you this is a pass
would you have any and specifically
whether it's because it's too small or
otherwise
would you have any cause for
embarrassment
would it in any way jeopardize your
standing in the company
they said no it's a brilliant script i
said great
then i am on we're on a phone you can't
see me but i'm on one knee
and i am begging you put it in steven's
briefcase
and he did steven read it
and he wanted to buy it now
no one was more stunned than i was
but i think this is a business that
turns on belief it's a business that
turns on passion it's a business that
you just got to go with your instincts
and get your head out of the game
sometimes because this is the fear
factor right this is the don't take risk
factor
speak the truth and make friends with
people
if i can get steven spielberg to want to
buy a script
i mean he didn't gary goldstein's name i
might as well have been the clerk at the
local convenience store
right
if an agent by the way had sent that
very same script on my behalf
it would have been absolutely a pass it
would never have gotten to stephen
because it wasn't about report wasn't
about an exploration it was like okay
it's a pass i get it
magic happens when you make yourself
available
when you make yourself known when you
care enough
to ask the right questions speak your
truth
the fact that i as a young guppy in the
business could get
the attention of steven spielberg and
maybe actually have a project together
was unthinkable people would have said
you're nuts
so do i think that it's hard to get your
script read i think it's hard to get
your script
read when you don't take risk
if you're relying on the wrong mindset
the wrong strategy
a blind query letter or relying on some
third party
we all of us need we deserve to get in
the game
we deserve to have relationships
to have cohorts and collaborators and
champions and fans and allies and
help one another mutually
at what point is too much though i think
many people in the entertainment
industry they're
long on enthusiasm but sometimes
certain times it can be too much maybe
they gotta sort of reel it back in
because you don't want to
hurt your reputation where oh it's that
person again
that happens often and
and it may be a very well intended
enthusiasm sure but the enthusiasm i
think you're referring to is a very
self-facing
enthusiasm okay so it's it's
it's it's maybe not intended to be
overly grand or braggadocio or any of
that but it may come across that way
or just too self-focused period
right so what i
would share with people is is that idea
that
vulnerability and honesty and truth
is not a push energy it's a pull energy
it's a very attractive energy
but don't spend the whole time talking
about yourself in fact
one of the great life lessons in not
just hollywood
but in life is fewer words
listen more the less you say
the fewer words you use to communicate
the more the other person remembers
if you talk too much this just becomes a
blur
but be other focused care about the
other person be curious
i think that curiosity and gratitude and
all you know
they're by words today but they're real
those are real energies
and if i approach you and i'm grateful
for you know thank you so much for
taking this call not over
being overly solicitous but just honest
um and asking about you know how you
know how long have you been there and
how did you get that job it's awesome
and
where do you aspire to go i would
probably be the only person
not only that day but that week month
and possibly longer
who's actually shown a genuine curiosity
or interest in you
because everyone else is in a rush to
get past you to the boss
it's easy to make friends in this
business actually
but you're right
you can't assault people with enthusiasm
and expect it to be an effective
strategy
it has to be very moderated less is more
quiet is better than loud truth is
better than
grandiosity so it's just being measured
because it's it's it's it's hard to you
know the g-force of people's enthusiasm
can be
um unwelcome if you were starting from
zero today how long do you think it
would take you
to get into a place like netflix to
pitch ideas
it's a great question i
i think it takes i think it takes a
while it's going to take a while
regardless
you have to be committed you have to be
willing to invest some time
in the olden days we networked
in a different way we showed up in
person for coffee breakfast
lunch dinner office meetings non-stop
the advantage of i mean the downside to
that was it was extraordinarily time
consuming
the upside of that was it was very
personal
the advantage of today is we can reach
anyone we want i can google anybody find
out how to get in touch with them where
they are
where they work if i don't know someone
at that agency or that streamer i can
find out who works there
i can reach out to them very quickly
digitally
i can speak to them on a phone i can get
them on a zoom i can do whatever you
know
those are those options are very
available to us so we can truncate the
time
but we need more frequency of
interaction because of the lack of
personal connection if we're not sitting
across a lunch table from them
it's different but again i
i really think that's incumbent on us to
be so
conscious and present and and aware of
what our
mission is and how we want to get there
i think the problem today is
we are separated by um technology
or we're connected by technology but
we're not physically in the room with
them
more often than not people are saying do
i need to be an la no you don't need to
be in la if you're in la you'd be having
the same number of meetings that you're
having right now
initially for the foreseeable so
technology's our friend but it's not as
personal the hardest part back then was
finding someone and getting together
physically with them so you could have a
relationship with them
today you can find identify someone
quickly in an instant online
and you can reach out to them instantly
by email by phone
what have you but you have to invest in
that
and make it personal you have to come
across in a different way
if you're if the if the intention is i
just want a pitch meeting
that's going to be hard especially at a
place like netflix
until you build your those bridges those
rapport-based bridges that let you walk
into that opportunity
so i think it's really less about how is
it the same or how is it different than
are we are we ready willing and able
to invest ourselves in bridge building
human bridge building or are we just
looking for someone to set us up for a
meeting
one is realistic one is not
you